Peter Parker what brings you into my
office today well I don't really know
how to explain it I got bit by this
glowing green spider and ever since then
I felt different yeah different how I
feel better
oh yeah strong okay faster Pete
always remember with great power comes
great responsibility
I'm sorry I know it's hard to hear but
uh yeah you were bit by a glowing green
radioactive spider it's radiation
sickness we have to get you on treatment
immediately that can't be true they can
be I'm a doctor and it is then how come
after I got bit
I felt you lightheaded that's literally
symptom number one of radiation sickness
but then I passed out and I was
clenching my covers reviewing heart also
a symptom do you think these are good
things that are happening to you listen
if I were sick how come I could do this
whoa you just jumped a normal height was
that supposed to be impressive now that
I have these gifts I feel like I should
combate evil Peter these delusions of
grandeur are side effects of a very
serious radiation sickness delusions
dude I was just swinging on a web
through New York City oh my god yeah we
live in Detroit and I just saw you get
out of a cab ten minutes ago you know
what with these abilities I could avenge
all the been give me a venn Junko Ben
he's fine he was in the cab with you
goodbye Peter have fun of the doctors
knowing that I'm very much alive and
well you know what Peter I think I can
do this what are you doing
stop fighting Peter
Peter that's enough now you were very
ill we need to start an aggressive
treatment plan and we cannot do that
with you looking around my office like
some kind of eight-legged monkey I knew
you're gonna say that because my
spider-sense that's it I'm done you kids
always come in here with the exact same
thing whoa wait whoa what do you mean
you kids you think you're the first
teenager aspiring reporter to come into
my office with a radioactive spider bite
hello Doctor hello what's all this in
what are all the other ones British
unfortunately yeah yeah well what about
that guy oh hey Doc I've been filled
never ever any agent sickness now I
don't care if it is canon
[Music]